well the world will be watching this
february 7th when super bowl 55 kicks
off in tampa bay
so many terrific story lines associated
with this game the betting handle is
going to be huge
you've got tom brady versus patrick
mahomes 18 years and 45 days age
difference between the two quarterbacks
in fact mahomes was six years old when
brady played in his first super bowl
now 25 years old mahomes will become the
youngest quarterback
to play in two super bowl games
buccaneers will be the first team to
play
a super bowl in their home stadium give
andy reid enough time boy an extra week
to prepare the guys lethal
the chiefs are three-point favorites the
over under is 56 and a half
this will be a rematch of an earlier
game won by the chiefs in tampa
and it was following that game where
analyst tony romo
made this prediction on cbs
do you want me to make a slight guess
here
i think there's a better there's a
there's a better than good chance i
don't know what even that percentage is
that these two are going to be here in
tampa all right he predicted it
championship sunday was huge wasn't a
couple of big games at packers and bucks
green bay fans will be questioning the
decisions made for quite a while now
first of all
how in the world does the defense let
the offense get behind them when the
last seconds of the first half and no
timeouts
boy this was christmas for brady and the
bucks worst case
scenario there should have been a long
field goal try then with over two
minutes to play
just over two social media lit up when
the packers elected
not to go for the touchdown to kick a
field goal on fourth and goal
following that incomplete pass there are
two sides to every argument but uh
boy don't you want to put the outcome in
roger's hands he never had a chance
erin did you agree with the decision to
kick it there on fourth down
why didn't you have a decision on that
one
yeah that wasn't my decision but i
understand
thinking about two minutes with uh all
of our timeouts but
yeah that wasn't my decision what went
into the decision to kick the field goal
there on fourth and eight and do you
regret that in hindsight
yeah anytime it doesn't work out you
always regret it right but
uh it was just the circumstances of
having three shots
and coming away with no yards um
and knowing that you not only need the
touchdown but you need the two points
well let's talk some occupy here's one
guy looking forward to a pair of games
this week alex petrangelo
isn't exactly a newcomer now but he's
still facing his old team the st
louis blues twice this week here in
vegas tomorrow's game will be the blues
first of eight games between the two
teams this season
remember the talented defenseman signed
that seven year 61.6 million dollar deal
he's got all sorts of numbers while he
played in st louis for eight years
but now he's with the knights he's got
three points already a goal two assists
in six games
it's also a night looking forward to
meeting those old teammates tomorrow
you know it's a little bit odd playing
each other eight times but
like i said just get over with maybe in
the first year play show as much as you
can so
um it'll be interesting uh tomorrow but
i think they said once you get a period
a couple shifts get a few bumps i think
that'll come
you move past that and you know play the
game i
i think everybody recognizes the
importance of these type of games
especially when
you know alex is a former captain and
stanley cup champion with that group
so i'm sure there's a lot of emotions
going through his
uh world with the first games back
against his former team
all right game tomorrow night at seven
o'clock runner rebels are playing their
stiffest conference test of the season
so far they tipped off with utah state
about 10 minutes ago or so rebels
looking to take advantage of their guard
play we'll have complete highlights and
reaction tonight
at 11 o'clock now in all the years here
brian utah state has only beaten unlv
twice in las vegas we'll see what
happens tonight crystal had that
coverage post game we could